I was having a lot of pain on my left foot, so I started taking B12 and the pain is much better.
What could be the reason? So your B vitamins are important for your muscles,
your muscle contraction, and also your circulation. So I cannot think of something
I had with B12 would have to do with pain in your soul or your foot, but if we thought
long and hard about it, it's a thought of like an acupuncture connection to what part of the
soul and what of your foot there's acupressure points that relate to different organs and things we
could get very esoteric, but that can have a lot of meaning. So you could easily google
acupressure points of your foot and you could see pictures of your feet and how it relates to
different organs and it could actually be that the B12 is helping that specific organ and that's why
the pain, why you had the pain in the foot and that's why helping that now the pain is gone. So
was there real connections? So there's a new age for anything, acupuncture and acupressure is not
anti-Christian in any stretch of the imagination, it's not, it is science. So something like that
that will take, um, could be related for sure.